une tradition sans cesse renouvelé porté
par une foule de petits rituels entre
ses danseurs d'expérience et les enfants
qui dès lors à hama casse noisette
qu'est ce que ça représente pour une
jeune étudiante qui fait du ballet de
danse et le rôle de claire c'est
vraiment un rêve c'est comme un rêve
devenu réalité puis je veux ça depuis
que je suis tout péter donc ouais ça
fait partie de ma vie sa vie plus petits
on s'éteint et pour certains c'est une
affaire de famille à la maison on est
souvent en train de pratiquer ensemble
c'est comme une famille mais c'est comme
une grande fête de noël
andré la prison et à sa 38e saison de
casse noisette
il en connaît tous les secrets tous les
rôles dans lesquels il voit grandir ses
protégés chaque rôle pour moi est
important les reines ont le plus petit
rôle à faire avec le plus de contrats
parce qu'ils travaillent faut qu'ils
soient impeccables ensemble des enfants
le sont extrêmement fiers de faire
chorégraphie minutieuse qui cache autre
balle est celui des coulisses et des
artisans les plus jeunes au doyen
interrompu font parler d'eux sont
obligés de lui dont le premier casse
noisette remonte à 1974
[Musique]
tartas noisette c'est plus de 165
personnage 300 costumes 1500 paires de
pointe par saison il ya un orchestre
dirigé pour la première fois par une
femme défi des chefs qui se sont fait de
regarder le pas des danseurs de respirer
avec eux de pouvoir faciliter en fait
leur travail pour qu'il puisse rayonner
un enfant sur le stage
rayonner inspiré transmettre la magie de
génération en génération
il sait manier la traverse radio canada
montréal